[Music]
and god spake all these words saying
i am the law thy god
which have brought thee out of the land
of egypt
out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any
grievan image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them
for i the law thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of
them that hate me
ensuring mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord
thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son
nor thy daughter thy manservant nor thy
maidservant nor thy cattle not a
stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it
honor thy father
and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery
thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant
nor his maidservant
nor his orcs nor his ass
nor anything
that is thy neighbors
god is good
come on say it as if you mean it god is
good
and all the time
how many of you love god genuinely can i
see your hand
i love god i also like him
if there are people you love you don't
like but i like god and i love god he's
a nice
person
he really is
the bible says of god in psalm 145
verse 17
the lord is righteous in all his ways
and holy
in all his works meaning
god cannot
do anything wrong
and so jesus says
they hated me without a cause
no one has ever had a cause a genuine
cause
to hate god
or be angry with god now we get angry
with him but it is causeless
and baseless
i thank god that he is god
and no one else
thank you very much for coming it is 7
i believe temperance should also apply
to preaching so i won't be very long
i won't take you beyond 8 15. is that
okay with you say yes quickly or no all
right
our subject for today the prince of
protocol
what did i say
the prince of protocol before i get into
that message because i'm an evangelist
and i love meeting people is there
anyone with us who is not a seventh-day
adventist mess your hand
oh
well how nice
please stand
let's look you over please
to the left what's your name
ann is a good name
anna where are you from
cuba i haven't been to cuba yet maybe
one day god will take me to cuba anna
thank you for coming and may god bless
you beyond your expectation thank you
anna you miss it what's your name
lordis
i had a friend many years ago called
lourdes and where are you from
lourdes idaho
i was in idaho a few years ago
enjoyed it right close to canada who
invited you lotus
okay okay anna you're an evangelist nice
to see you lotus thank you so much for
coming may the lord bless you anna and
lord this yes the sister to the right
suzanne butler hello suzanne
how are you
where are you from
kentucky
the military brought you to columbus
georgia when the military orders you
obey so you came to columbus georgia it
is so nice to see you sister butler who
invited you
of the store in columbus ah well i'm
glad you accepted the invitation sister
butler may the lord bless you place his
hand of mercy upon you and never remove
it all right you may be seated
yes my brother what's your name
john
well that's as good a bible name as you
can get john how are you
how are you
where are you from
missouri
all right who invited you john
same guy
we have
anna invited lourdes and the same guy
invited john
well god bless you same guy thank you
for bringing brother john john thanks
for coming and may the lord walk with
you all the days of your life you may be
seated
yes my sister what's your name
who
tricia hello trisha
how are you
where are you from
you're from here there's a town in my in
alabama called here okay well it's nice
to have you trisha who invited
you who
sister shaw
who is that
ah okay and somebody else
okay what's your name
amy all right trisha we're glad you came
may the lord's presence go with you
wherever you go on this earth and when
god's presence is with you you are
blessed and protected say amen for
trisha
all right yes my sister what's your name
donna hi donna where are you from
chicago
afghanistan many times
and who invited you donna
god
donna
you're in special company god invited
you and you could not find a reason to
refuse that's good thinking donna thanks
for coming and may god continue to
invite you into all his blessings all
his blessings until he comes to save you
and your family say amen for donna
all right my dear patient sister what's
your name
your name is who
teresita
garcia
now where exactly are you from
cuba is a good place
do you know anna
or pre-cuba
not post cuba okay
all right well god loves cuba
64 years in miami terracita garcia god
bless you who invited you
jesus
jesus invited you god invited don the
same thing well it's
yes
okay
well
where we thank god for that
terror seater god bless you thanks for
coming and may god use you to bless
other people
say amen for all our guests
that was weak say it again
god is good
and all the time
yes indeed do three favors for me one
was already mentioned make sure these
things are turned off
mine is off
i thank god for technology but god
didn't give us technology to disrespect
him can you say amen
so make sure you can't take one of these
into the courtroom as far as i know
you've got to leave it outside and if
you sneak it in you can't use it or
you'll have a vacation at the expense of
the government and you don't want that
so let's be reverend in the presence of
god is that okay with you
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
many times i listen to preachers on
television
and sometimes i literally ask god please
shut him up
don't kill him but just shut him up
because of what they're saying
but i want to speak god's words are you
with me
when god created he said the bible says
and god said
every day
this
not and i said
or biden said
or trump said
or putin said
god said
and if god said and the universe came
if you go by god said he'll change your
universe
this
jesus said
man shall not live by bread alone finish
the verse
but by every word that proceedeth out of
the mouth of god
not chris lord dollar
god
not td jx
not benny him
god
not
not but god
and so remember this promise in jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord put
forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth
i ask god publicly put his words in my
mouth and since the bible says and this
is the confidence that we have in him
that if we ask anything according to his
will
he here with us
if you pray and say god
put your words
in that man's mouth
what am i about to say
he will hear you
he will answer and the words i speak
will be safe for you to receive into
your mind are you with me
favor number three
think
think you look at me as though why is he
saying that because most people don't
think
you see if people would think they would
not eat some of the things they eat
is this mic working
if people would think they would not
drink some of the things they drink
they would not date some of the people
they date
now you don't like me anymore
if we would stop and think we would not
attend some of the churches we attended
think
isaiah 18 come now let us reason
together we serve a reasonable god
satan
is unreasonable
god
is reasonable
spray father in heaven
speak through me i humble myself before
you use me as you see fit i pray
in jesus name amen
genesis 1 reading verse 26
i have to find these verses quickly
because time moves very fast so i may
have to run ahead of you genesis 1 26
the bible says and god said let us make
man how in our image after our likeness
stop
and god said
let us make man
in our image
after our likeness let's make them like
us now that does not mean god made us to
be gods because god cannot be made
i need to say that again because this
site said nothing
god cannot be made
are you with me
anything created cannot be god because
god has always been are you with me it's
one big mysteries it's always been there
that's what makes him god he has no
beginning and he will have no end
now he made us to be
like him
but you cannot be god
but you're called upon through jesus
christ to be
godly
and god like if that's clear say amen
and so god said let us make man in our
image
after our likeness which means god made
us to have fellowship with him
god does not believe in loneliness
although jesus suffered loneliness to
save us
listen carefully
who being the brightness of his glory
and the express image of his person and
upholding all things by the word of his
power when he had by himself purged our
sins
mark 14 50 and all the disciples forsook
him
and fled
jesus cried out my god my god
yes the father turned away disciples
took off running if the father turned
away the holy spirit turned away and the
angels turned away
jesus understands
loneliness
are you following me
when he had by
himself but he suffered that that you
and i might not suffer it because god is
not a god of loneliness
god is not a god of sin but jesus took
our sins
let us make man
in our image
after our likeness god wanted to
fellowship with us and so he made us
like himself because we believe in the
saying birds of a feather
flog together
if you go to a convention of seventh-day
adventists from all over the world
who are you looking for
people you know
so you can feel
at home
now you love all the brethren yes
but not all the brethren are from
alabama are you with me
here's a brother from papua new guinea
who doesn't speak english or someone
from korea you're looking for you say hi
hi hi but you're looking for
those from alabama who can understand
god is the same way
i want to fellowship with people who are
like i am
god made us
for fellowship face to face
but something happened tell me what that
thing is in one word quickly sin now go
to isaiah 59 we'll read verses one and
two
do you have it you're too slow
you don't have isaiah 59 102 yet someone
told me i'm too harsh with congregations
but i don't mind being harsh with
adventist congregations
because we used to be called what
uh-huh we no longer call that
and somebody has to stop that and
reverse the trend now do you have isaiah
59 more than two
do you have the king james version like
i have or you can read with me behold
the lord's hand is not shortened that it
cannot save not his ear heavy that he
cannot hear now carefully
but your iniquities come on have
separated between you and your god and
your sins have hid his faith from you
that he will not hear you now we've got
a problem here is a god who loves
fellowship and sin has occurred
and that fellowship ended
listen to genesis 3
from verse 7
and the eyes of them both were opened
and they knew that they were naked and
they sold fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons and they heard
this wasn't guesswork
they heard the voice of the lord god
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and adam and his wife come on finish
it
hid themselves stop
sin
reversed what god had in mind
and now the sinner
avoids god naturally
i didn't say the sinner avoids church
because church is where you meet other
sinners and birds of a feather flock
together the sinner avoids god
who said crucify him when the romans
said let him go
the church
sin
your iniquities have separated between
you and your god in other words in order
to fellowship with god as he desires sin
must go
how much of it
all
now question for you but let me pray
again father as i continue please lord
restrict my carnal nature strangle it i
pray and use me i ask in jesus name amen
do we have fellowship with god right now
yes or no
yeah why do you hesitate yes
how
okay the word of god that's correct good
answer there's some other answers i'm
looking for
okay prayer all right
can you come into the presence of god
yes or no
yes
how
jesus christ
god bless anna
through jesus christ
john 14 6
i am the way come on say the truth and
the life finish it now no man cometh
unto the father but by me now there is a
way to come to god
put a name on that way jesus christ
neither is there salvation in any other
for there is none on the name under
heaven given among men whereby we must
be saved who is that name what is that
name jesus christ for there is one god
and one mediator between god and men
finish it for me the man christ jesus
listen to me what is our topic for
tonight the prince
of protocol
who is that
jesus
it is he
that prepares us to return to the
presence of god
why did i say the prince of protocol
when heads of states have to meet long
before they actually meet
the the those who the the minister of
protocol from one country
meets with a minister of protocol from
another country
and they work out how this thing will
work
a few years ago an american actress
called angelina jolie had to go to
buckingham palace to meet the queen now
when you say the queen people
immediately think of queen elizabeth
although they're many queens all over
the world but she's the one who comes
this is the queen
and she had to dress a certain way
when you come to the queen's present you
come into the room you wait
then she enters
she has to speak first
that's not snobbishness that's protocol
she extends her hand first
after she speaks then you speak
but
when a general enters a room where there
are soldiers what do the soldiers do
protocol
when i was a little boy when the teacher
entered our classroom
we stood up
that doesn't happen now but
they stood up protocol now
there is a protocol for entering the
presence of god
and jesus said
i am the way
the truth
and the life
no man cometh unto the father
but by me
there are many instances in the bible of
angels appearing to people
every time an angel appeared to human
being what was the reaction of the human
being
scared to death
the angels have to keep saying what
fear not
which means not even with angels can a
human being have a comfortable
interaction because the angel is too
powerful his his glory is too bright
one angel came down at the tomb of
christ and all the roman guards felt as
if they were dead
the prince of protocol
through his sacrifice
prepares us to return
to fellowship with god but not only with
god to unfallen beings and to angelic
beings
having said that
go to zechariah chapter three
it's a quarter to eight
book do i say
what's the book right after zechariah
very good very good those on the left
what's wrong with right
you have zechariah
chapter three
let's read from verse one
are you ready
and he showed me joshua the high priest
standing where before the angel of the
lord and satan standing where at his
right hand to do what resist him or
accuse him listen to me carefully one of
the devil's most effective tools against
us is to remind us of how useless we are
how bad we are you committed a terrible
sin in 1966 you did this in 1975 even
though god has forgiven you
and many of us cannot accept god's
forgiveness because the devil reminds us
and so we have a choice either believe
what the devil says or believe if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from
all
we either believe that or we fall to the
devil's constant accusations satan
standing at his right hand to resist him
or to accuse him and to oppose him
and the lord said unto satan the lord
rebuked me o satan even the lord that
have chosen jerusalem rebuke thee is not
this a brand plucked out of the fire now
the angel of the lord there is christ
who speaks for us
against satan
so when satan tells you you know good
listen to the other voice
that tells you i have loved you with an
everlasting love you are the apple come
on of my eye
when your family rejects you when my
mother and my father forsake me then the
lord will take me up psalm 27 verse 10.
so the devil will always speak and god
cannot god will not shut him up because
god has to allow us to be
tested
when he brings up all sins
we simply say
i thank god for forgiveness
i thank god
i've been cleansed you're talking to a
different person
satan standing at his right hand to
resist him now verse 3 now joshua was
clawed with filthy garments and stood
before the angels that is christ
when you read filthy garments what comes
to mind immediately sin
the physical sin clean garments
righteousness yes
clothed with filthy garments now joshua
represented the entire nation of israel
zechariah is seeing a vision
and god is trying to teach him something
he answered and speaking to those that
stood before him saying verse 4 take
away the filthy garments from him
who's speaking
yes take away
but you've got to see that put them on
me
what did john say behold the lamb of god
that taketh away the greek word means to
carry or to bear you know many people
walk with backpacks i see them on planes
all the time they turn around in the
plane and hit you in your head they are
called these backpacks
christ carries a backpack of sin that he
did not commit
and is the largest backpack you ever saw
because he carries the sins of the world
and so jesus says take away the filthy
garments from him and unto him i said
behold read with me now i have what
caused thy iniquity come on to pass from
thee and i will clothe thee with change
of raiment
but we see that in genesis 3 verse 21
and unto adam also unto his wife did the
lord god make courts of skins and clothe
them and we know from zechariah when we
combine zechariah and genesis what is
not mentioned is genesis is told to us
in zechariah in genesis we're not told
god removed the aprons but we know he
had to because we cannot remove our sins
and so we see
christ leading out in removing the
filthy garments that's what christ did
in eden
by the way it was christ who did it not
the father because the moment adam
sinned all face-to-face communication
with the father ceased
and it was only through christ
take away the filthy garments from him
and unto him he said behold i have
caused thine iniquity to pass from thee
and i will clothe thee with change of
raymond verse 5 and i said let them set
a fair miter upon his head and they said
so they set a fair might upon his head
now what's the miter that's what the
priest wore
it was always god's desire that we would
be a kingdom of priests are you with me
that was his desire for egypt for
israelites when he brought them out of
egypt if now therefore if he will obey
my voice indeed exodus 19 5 and keep my
commandments then there shall be a
peculiar treasure unto me above all
people for all the world is mine and you
shall be into me a kingdom of priests
an entire nation teaching other nations
but because of unbelief and sin the
system changed it was always god's will
that we be a kingdom of prison so god
puts a mitre
and clothing with raymond and the angel
of the lord stood by now listen to six
and
seven
and the angel of the lord protested unto
you protested means he spoke forcefully
unto joshua saying
thus saith the lord of hosts now read
with me if thou will walk in my ways
pause let's count the words if
let's take out the if thou wilt walk in
my ways
give me one word for that
obey
what's the first word if
people think they can tell god anything
they like
god has
conditions
now his love is unconditional
most of his blessings are conditional
if
thou wilt walk in my way
and if come on read the next name thou
wilt
keep my charge
give me
wilt thou will keep my charge give me
one word obey
then thou shall also
judge my house
and shall also
keep my courts now
read the last part of that carefully and
i will give thee places one
where
now wait a minute who are these that
stand by with whom christ says the
redeemed will walk he says i will give
you places to walk among these that
stand by question is who with these or
who are these that stand by stand by
where we're looking at the throne room
of god
are you with me
now let's go to daniel seven we read
nine and ten our subject is what
the prince of protocol
daniel seven let's read nine and ten
you have daniel
there are two books that are very well
known to seventh-day adventists what are
those two books
daniel and revelation yes you want to
understand what's going on today study
daniel and revelation particularly the
whole bible but particularly those two
books
i beheld till the thrones were cast down
and the ancient of this did sit who's
what garment was whiter snow under hair
of his head like the pure world his
wheels were like his throne was like the
burning fire and his wheels as well
burning fire burning flame for the
throne fire for the wheels
now the verse goes on to say what
a fiery stream did what issued and came
forth from before him because god is a
consuming fire keep reading
thousand thousands come on minister unto
him keep reading ten thousand times ten
thousands come on
who are they
angels
how much is ten thousand times ten
thousand that was a hundred million
and that's the best that daniel could do
you see when human beings view heavenly
events they struggle to describe have
daniel said thousand times ten thousand
times ten thousand but a hundred million
at least
jesus says
i will give you places to walk
among these that stand standby
go to revelation 5.
now john is seeing the same place same
thing
looking into heaven looking in the
throne room of god
revelation 5
let's read verse 11.
do you have that the last book of the
bible revelation 5
reading verse 11 what does that verse
say
and i beheld and i heard the voice of
many angels round about the throne and
the beast and the elders and the number
of them was ten thousand times ten
thousand come on and thousands of
thousands saying with a loud voice what
worship the lamb
which was slain
to receive what power and wisdom and
riches and strength and honor and glory
and blessing angels
all around the throne of god i want to
stress this heavily because there are
different kinds of angels
and they have different levels of
authority
who's the highest angel in heaven right
now
gabriel he has more power than any other
angel
there's an interesting statement that
jesus told disciples
when the unclean spirit is gone out of a
man
he walketh through dry places seeking
rest
and finding none he saith i will return
on my house once i came out i'm going
back
when he cometh he findeth it swept and
garnished now listen carefully then go
with he the demon and taketh
seven more demons can you finish it more
wicked than himself now reason with me
may the lord give me the right words
seven other demons more wicked than
himself
now who were those wicked demons
years before
they were holy angels
now the same way
in the wicked states some had more power
to do wickedness than others in the holy
state come on talk to me
some had more power to do god's will
than others
are you with me
are you sure
there were levels of there still are
levels of power and authority among the
angels
when some of them fell they took those
differences of power with them
the most powerful angel was lucifer when
he fell he lost his position but he took
all his power
keep this in mind now
and listen to jesus
as he's surrounded by seraphim and
cherubim and all kinds of angels and he
looks at nasty joshua whom he just
forgave
he said i will give you the privilege of
walking around
with these
but there's a protocol joshua
you just can't walk up to an angel and
start
chatting are you following me you just
don't rush up from there and go shake
the president's hand the secret service
will tackle you to the ground
there's a protocol for fellowship with
god there is a protocol for
fellowshipping with unfallen beings
angels beings that live on other worlds
that have never sinned that know nothing
about sin there is a protocol
and the minister the prince of protocol
is jesus christ
and through his word thy word is a lamp
unto my feet come on and a light unto my
path and through the word of god
we are taught
we are trained we are prepared
to fellowship
face to face with god
and with angels without being terrified
and scared out of our wits
christ
is the one who prepares us
he is the father's
prince or minister
of protocol
he came
took our condition
to understand from our side
somebody say man
rich people
i mean billionaires in russia they call
them oligarchs who have yachts that cost
600 million dollars
they
may or may not understand poverty
but even if they do
they're not about to willingly become
poor are you following me
an elephant may understand a mouse but
no elephant is about to become a mouse
jesus christ
became
one of us
even if he had become like adam before
adam sinned
it would have been humiliating
but he came
after thousands of years of unbridled
deterioration
that's why when god told moses to build
a sanctuary the sanctuary had walls it
had everything except a floor
which means
when the high priest ministered where
was he standing
but then god cursed the earth in genesis
3 verse 17
curse is the ground for thy sake wasn't
it cursed again when abel killed kaneki
label wasn't it cursed by the flood the
high priest walked on an earth that was
three times cursed
that tells you how closely christ our
high priest identified with us
now understanding how we are without
joining us in our sins
he can and knowing what it's like to be
divine because he was both
who else is more qualified
to guide us and prepare us for
fellowship with god
but someone who understands us
and understands god the bible says in
revelation 22 4 and they shall see
his face
but we know from exodus 33 verse 28
there shall no man see me
and live
even moses
you know god said
i will give dreams and visions to my
prophets but not to moses i will speak
to him faith
moses came off the mount exodus 34 his
face was shining with the glory of god
but he didn't see the face of god
you cannot see god's face
as long as you carry this sinful nature
even though you are converted you're
transformed you haven't sinned since
1947 even though all of that may be the
case you cannot look into the face of
god until this mortal come on talk to me
puts on immortality and this corruptible
puts on incorruption
listen to christ you know this you can
say it with me
listen carefully listen microscopically
let me pray father as i continue lord
please please talk to me to god i pray
in jesus name amen
let not your heart be troubled
you believe in god
believe also in me
in my father's house are many mansions
if it were not so
i would have let me pau i love that
expression so much listen again if it
were not so
i would have told you
if i wanted a man to have two wives come
on
i would have told you
am i talking to myself
if i wanted you to smoke come on
i would have told you
if i had changed the sabbath come on
that's the way god is he tells you what
what you need to know
i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come again now tell me the next
few words
but wait a minute
aren't we already his
what does it mean by receive you unto
myself
he said i will so it hadn't happened
ah you're not with me it's my fault
let me try again i will when you say i
will it means something has not yet
happened jesus says i will come again i
will receive you unto myself
so as much as you and i have a
relationship with christ now it is not
yet ideal
because he goes on to say that where i
am
you can pray from now until doomsday
you are not where jesus is literally
does christ still have physical flesh
yes or no yes
so he cannot be
everywhere at the same time where are
you on earth where is christ
you're not where he is
can you touch him physically no
will the day come when you can touch him
yes
the bible says we walk by faith not by
sight i understand that i believe it but
i still want that day to come
when i can look god right in the face on
my knees
and say father
the day will come and i will look at
gabriel
that's the angel gabriel
the day will come when i will look at my
guardian angel who kept me from a
thousand dangers despite all the
headaches i gave him
and see him
without my knees knocking
i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come i am not sending gabriel to
get you
you know people send
send a cab to pick me up
i'm coming
you know i understand it because i
travel all over the world and i went to
the airport and the church sends someone
to pick me up
or whomever the university sends someone
to and that's fine i'm happy
christ
i am coming to pick you up
i will come again and receive you unto
myself
that where i am
there you may be also now he represents
us yes we know that
because we sit in heavenly places in
christ jesus but i want to sit in
heavenly places literally
and so i
thank god for the prince of protocol
the gospel is the protocol necessary
to enjoy
face-to-face fellowship with god
the gospel is the protocol necessary to
enjoy
constant daily communion with these that
stand by who are they heavenly beings
angels those in unfallen worlds and i
want that
because i don't have it now
yes i have christ yes i've got the holy
spirit yes by faith i have that
connection i want it by faith and by
reality on a three day you know when
jesus rose from the dead and he appeared
to the disciples they did not believe he
was real they thought he was a ghost he
said handle me and he must have grabbed
him that's what he said handle me i want
to handle jesus
now right now i handle him by faith
because he's the word
i want to handle him
if i follow the protocol
that day will come
and the heart and soul of that protocol
is get rid finish my words
come on finish my words
get rid of
sin
because sin brought the separation
what is sin tell me quickly
the transgression of the law and what
was it
that uh
the angel of the lord jesus christ said
to zechariah to zach to joshua
if thou wilt walk in my ways what's the
word for that
and if thou keep my charge what's the
word for that let me show you obey again
because this is a a lifestyle center for
health go to exodus 15 quickly then i'll
close exodus 15.
obedience is the condition for the
protocol to work
obedience which is what we hate but
that's the condition
you have exodus 15
and i'm sure this is the verse with
which you're very familiar now let's
read from verse 15 and said
first statement if thou wilt
diligently come on
now if i will diligently hearken unto
them
aha give me one word for diligently
hearken unto the voice of the lord thy
god one word obey read the next
statement and will do that which is
give me one word for that
obey don't hesitate obey keep going and
will
give air to his
give me one word for that
finish it and will
all his that give me one word
now read the next day man i will put
none of these diseases upon you
which i have brought
upon the egyptian
what's the condition for health
okay
but health is both physical and
until you're healthy spiritually you're
not fully healthy
there'll be millions of people with
normal blood pressure in hell
with the right body body mass index in
hell
because their health did not extend to
the spiritual level
you know we say the first slot the eight
laws of health and we say what's the
first one
nutrition that's fine god made the tree
from which adam you know that was
supposed to nourish adam and eve all the
fruit trees yeah what's the second one
exercise what's the third one water the
next one
sunlight yes
what's the next one
templar was the next one rest was the
next one
and the last one trust in god
but for me the first law of health is
confess your sins
so i need to start a lifestyle center
the first law of health listen to me is
confess your sins because sickness is a
result of sin
you carry a grudge you depress your
immune system i don't care how many gyms
you join
you won't forgive you damage your health
physically
develop an ulcer you wonder what is the
food my wife cooks no your wife is a
good cook there's someone you haven't
forgiven and it's eating away god did
not separate physical from spiritual or
mental they're all connected they're all
sympathetic one to the other i'm saying
to you the protocol has one condition
obey
and through christ
obedience is possible
and so jesus said
if he keep my commandments
he shall abide in my love
even as i
which means what i did come on
you can do
you're looking at me very nicely but do
you understand what i'm saying
jesus is saying what i did come on
you can do
let me be
stronger what i did you are required
to him that overcometh
when i grant to sit with me in my throne
come on
even as i overcame
same way
you call me master on lord and ye say
well for so i am if i then your lord and
master have washed your feet
also to wash one another's feet for i
have given you an example that you
should do as i have done
let me close this strong emphasis the
life christ lived on the earth notice my
words the life he lived on the earth in
this flesh
is exactly the life required of us
not one
like it
the same life
it's uh 13 after eight did i say i let
you go at 8 15
but i'm not god
and my word fails sometimes but let me
slip this in for you listen to this
verse listen carefully
let this mind
be in you come on which was also
now did the verse say let a similar mind
no
the same mind
that jesus had
we must have
and if that's the case
then that mind will produce what the
same life
the problem is
we don't believe in
we believe in a decent life and i like
this don't misunderstand me all my
neighbors are decent i'm very happy
but decency can be achieved without god
you didn't hear what i said
you don't need god to be decent most
atheists are decent
you need god to be christ-like
let this mind be in you
with that mind
the day will come where god will combine
the mind with the right physical
condition so we can fellowship with god
face to face
i thank god for the prince
of protocol
jesus christ the gospel is the means
whereby god is preparing us
for face to face fellowship with him i
the thought of seeing god is a it gives
me a good concussion
to look right at god
you know
the the our scientists sent off a space
probe james webb to take pictures of how
the world was made they could have done
it very cheaply
are you with me
this book tells you how the world was
made but they built a telescope billions
of dollars to try to figure out how the
world was made and there's a cheap way
to do it but anyway it's a
i don't know what that telecope is
seeing
but you'll never see god
you want to see god look at jesus
this is
i said what did i just say
you want to see god look at jesus
he that have seen me
now that has to go one more level he
that have seen you have seen jesus
and preaching several sermons in one you
see
8 15 okay 8 20.
the relationship between god and jesus
must be reproduced in the relationship
between jesus and the believer
we don't believe it
the relationship between listen to jesus
he tells us that listen carefully
if ye keep
my commandments
he shall abide
in my love now
even as i have kept my father's
commandments and abide
so we have a balanced equation
jesus
obeyed stayed in the father's love we
obey stay in the love of christ
the relationship between god and christ
must be reproduced in the relationship
between the believer and christ
how many of you will say father
i open my heart and allow the prince of
protocol to work in me to prepare me for
face-to-face fellowship with you do you
believe do you mean that with all your
heart and soul stand up with me
we believe all sorts of we believe
politicians
we believe anything they say
but we won't believe god
we just believe earthly people but will
not believe god
the politician comes to this place and
says listen if you've brought me to
office i will i will uh put gold under
your house
and say okay
oh they say whatever they say people
believe it
when god speaks
we doubt him
just before i pray
god wants to hang out with you more than
you want to hang out with him
because god is a god of fellowship
god is a god of fellowship
not loneliness that's why when christ
was in gethsemane god sent an angel to
help him you know why the disciples were
sleeping
now the disciples should have held jesus
and you know supported him and
encouraged him the cheerleading squad
should have been the disciples they
slept and god will not leave you alone
and so he sent an angel but because
jesus was human at the time if god sent
an angel to jesus he must send one to
you
because god is no respecter come on
and jesus was a person
when christ was tempted
matthew 4 11
then the devil left him and angels
because he was weak when the temptation
ended because in the 40 days faster he
was weak god sent angels to sustain him
i'm telling you god will do the same for
you
because god does not believe in people
battling by themselves
and god is itching for the day when you
and i
having understood all the protocol of
the gospel
through christ
will one day
speak
face to face with god
with angels
with beings in unfallen worlds
let's forget our admiration for the
rappers let's forget our admonition for
whomever the rock stars and the baseball
players and the basketball players let's
yearn to fellowship with god if that's
your desire can you say amen
let's pray father in heaven we thank you
for the promise of face-to-face
fellowship with you the great sovereign
of the university god that is only
through christ fathers we stand we
recommit our lives to this jesus this
prince of protocol who through the
gospel prepares us for that face-to-face
fellowship which was lost through sin
as we leave help us to believe and
understand that this applies to us as
individuals first
not as a church as individuals because
when you made adam eve did not exist and
when you made eve and was sleeping you
stress individual
first and the gospel deals with
individuals first and so god let us
believe that you desire me let everyone
see me
to have fellowship with you
bless us as we leave let angels watch
over us tonight day god father put a
special blessing on all our friends who
are not seventh-day adventists touch
them let them know
that the god whom they encounter tonight
loves them and desires to save them
if it pleases you to give us life
tomorrow let us commit that life to your
glory we pray in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen
you